DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hello,
my name's Dustin Kirkland.
I'm a product manager at Google.
And I'm here with
Michelle Casbon.
And she is in
developer relations,
working on the Kubeflow project.
We're currently on the
path to Kubeflow 1.0.
It's coming soon.
What can we expect to
see in Kubeflow 1.0?
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah, so we
just rolled our 0.5 release
a few months ago.
And we're preparing
for 0.6, which is sort
of the last leg towards 1.0.
And we're really focusing on
taking a lot of the learnings
from our initial
users, so the ones that
have been with us from
the very beginning.
Kubeflow is about a year and
a half old at this point.
We launched in KubeCon
Austin, a year and a half ago.
And at this point, we're
focusing on hardening our APIs.
So we've been
listening to our users.
We have a great
contributor base,
and they've given us a lot of
feedback on what works for them
and what doesn't, which
features they like,
which features they don't.
And so now we're
hardening those,
we're making sure that
people who've installed it
can upgrade in a
seamless way, enterprise
features like multi-tenancy,
more individualized,
granular security controls,
that kind of thing.
So making it a robust
experience for enterprise, for
startups, for
everyone in between.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And
as I understand it,
one of the real
goals of Kubeflow
is to get these AI/ML tools in
the hands of data scientists
without those data
scientists also
having to be
Kubernetes-certified system
administrators, right?
MICHELLE CASBON: That's right.
We want to provide access
for both DevOps and data
scientists, machine learning
engineers, everyone in between.
So we don't want to take away
any control at the Kubernetes
layer.
That's really important
for enterprises.
But we don't want
a data scientist
to have to learn about
Docker, and containers,
and everything--
all the nuances of the
Kubernetes platform.
So one of the first components
of Kubeflow was JupyterHub.
And we've really
expanded on that
to make it possible
for data scientists
to not really ever
leave that environment,
to be able to build a model,
train it, and deploy it
directly from within
an environment
that they're familiar with.
And so the idea
is that DevOps has
a lot of fine-grained
controls, but they
empower data scientists
to do everything
they need to get their work
done in a scalable way that
is sustainable, where
everyone's happy,
everyone's sort of
living in the space
that they're comfortable
in, and not stepping
on each other's toes.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And
in terms of community,
and the community
contributions around Kubeflow,
Google fits into
that, of course.
Maybe tell us a
little bit about what
Google does in the
community, and where
else you see community
participation in the Kubeflow
project.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah,
so Kubeflow started out
as a Google project.
A year and a half ago it
was launched at KubeCon.
And we've seen an
incredible uptick
in the number of contributors,
number of PRs that we've seen.
One of my favorite
new features was just
debuted a week ago at
our community call.
We had a few
researchers in Italy,
they showed this demo of some
notebook features, so something
that makes it even easier
for data scientists
to essentially add
tags to a notebook
so that it will automatically
run within pipelines.
And this whole story,
the more people
use the platform,
the more they come up
with ideas that we
haven't considered before,
and the more that
community base grows.
So we had a really successful
happy hour last night.
I think there were
only a few Googlers.
But we packed this tiny
neighborhood bodega.
There were people spilling
out into the streets.
And it was people from
all over the world.
And that's really
encouraging to see.
We have a lot of big
support from Azure.
We have a bunch of
AWS integration.
It doesn't just run on
the Google Cloud Platform.
It's designed to be a
portable platform for running
machine learning anywhere you
have a Kubernetes cluster.
It uses vanilla Kubernetes APIs.
And the influx of people
coming from all over and adding
to that has been
incredibly encouraging.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Yeah, I can see it.
And tell me a little bit
about the applications
you're starting to see,
maybe some the ones
you're most excited about
seeing developed on top
of the Kubeflow platform.
MICHELLE CASBON: So the thing
that I'm most excited about
is--
part of the keynote was
a few people from CERN
who came up and talked
about this public data set
that they have.
So they replicated the
Higgs boson experiment,
and they did that on GKE.
And so I'm meeting
with them very soon.
I get to actually visit
CERN and take a tour.
I've been wanting to do
this for so many years.
If you've seen the
documentary "Particle Fever,"
it is incredible.
And so I get to
see that in person.
And I'm hoping that, when
I meet with the team,
that I can come up
with some sort of way
to get them running on Kubeflow.
Because it would be amazing
to work with that data set
and to sort of help them
along their journey.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Michelle,
thank you very much.